let's take a moment to meditate on the
fact that this code like many class
patterns in JavaScript has two distinct
and very different sections this will be
true of every pseudo-classical prototype
and functional shared class that you
write in one section you will find that
you're specifying how all the instances
of a class should be similar in the case
of the pseudo-classical pattern these
similarities are generally stored as
properties of the prototype object in
the other section you'll be writing code
that specifies how each instance should
be different from all the other
instances as with most programming
languages this will take place inside
the body of the constructor function and
it'll allow us to specify how one
instance of a class will be different
from another instance of a class all of
the work that gets done to specify that
Amy and Ben have unique locations is
done inside that constructor function
for now this is just an interesting
observation about classes but knowing
that these two categories of code exist
for every class will become very
important later when we start to discuss
sub-classing looking back at the
functional version of this class for a
moment it's also interesting to notice
that functional classes without shared
methods make no such distinction in this
style all the code for both categories
appears in one place the similarities
and the differences across instances
appear here indented two spaces inside
the car function depending on your
perspective you could call this an asset
or a failing of the functional pattern